la catedral ortodoxa de esa estaba
siendo que de costumbre la invasión rusa
ha llevado a que muchos más feligreses
la visiten para pedir por el fin de la
guerra y la protección de su ciudad
disminuyan
toda la comunidad religiosa de odessa
está unida actualmente con una misma
idea y acciones para proteger el país y
niell
el dolor del arzobispo y odiar es
visible la iglesia ortodoxa ucraniana se
ha visto atrapada en esta guerra condenó
la invasión rusa desde el primer día y
pidió al patriarca de la iglesia en
moscú para que intercediera ante
vladimir putin sus acciones no han
tenido éxito en la agresión nos duele el
doble pues viene de un pueblo con el que
compartimos la misma perú la del millón
de habitantes yo de esa más del 80% son
ortodoxos el idioma mayoritario es el
ruso y miles de familias están
repartidas a ambos lados de la frontera
este es el caso de este grupo de amigos
que discuten sobre la invasión
tengo nacionalidad ucraniana pero nací y
crecí en una comunidad de ruso parlante
nunca me cabe en la cabeza que esto esté
pasando
[Música]
vladimir nación ucrania cuando era parte
de la unión soviética pero para víctor
las relaciones aún más estrecha nación
rusia donde vive gran parte de su
familia muy bien ya que usted ve en mi
cara la de un hombre que ha sido
reprimido porque habla ruso esto es
absurdo y muy grande en estas calles
pocos se olvidan que una de las
justificaciones de putin para invadir
ucrania era la defensa de los rusos
parlantes y no danza o vivos aquí todos
hablan ruso
usted puede chequear en la iglesia solo
dos misas en ucrania no son más ni
granger o de esas una ciudad cosmopolita
acoge más de 120 nacionalidades y
decenas de confesiones que se han unido
para dar apoyo a quienes resisten en la
ciudad como en esta iglesia católica
porque no tenemos por ser minoría sino
por la guerra que es terrible ahora
en estos cultos saben bien que una
victoria rusa significará la pérdida de
la libertad una pesadilla que nadie
quiere enfrentar